this is just like jamming in solution
episode and also i never talk about my
skincare routine people ask me all the
time you're one of the few people i feel
like i can really dig in because you're
a product tour in the best way i'm i'm
dying for this moment especially the
updated version because we haven't had
this conversation a couple years i want
to do first of all just like speed round
of life hacks in general of things that
have helped me change my life that i
would be a selfish bitch for not sharing
so all of our skincare products none of
it is absorbing into your skin if you
haven't exfoliated your skin or if you
haven't micro needled or
um i really want to know about
micronutrients derma roll derma so
here's the thing we have the top layer
of our skin is mostly dead skin so when
we put our products on we're kind of
just like caking onto
it's not really absorbing you know into
our skin most of it unless you've
exfoliated unless you've done some kind
of astringent you know this the lotion
p50 or p70 by biologic research i use a
lot um the uh skin eternal serum um uh
with alpha lipoic acid in it um that i
do source naturals we are those to
exfoliate that removal put them on on
top after i've derma rolled okay so this
is a derma roller this is the one that i
use um and it's just like a little tool
that has little tiny needles in it
that before i apply any of my product
i'm always going to micro needle not or
derma roll micro needling micro needling
is that's actually when you go to like a
facial list and it's a needle that has a
little bit of electricity in it and they
make little holes in your face and then
put stuff on it and it what it does is
it um
creates a little trauma in your
epidermis so that the because the trauma
response is producing collagen and
that's what tightens everything okay so
this was my question because i heard
david sinclair talk about microneedling
and how it's anti-aging yeah does derma
rolling do the same benefit or do you
need to get microneedling and micro
needling i i would just you know if
you're microneedling with the wrong
person it's not going to do
a ton i do ulthera so ulthera is a emily
did it with me in uh at doctor so
conover wellness in um south carolina uh
kelly conover and dr conover she's like
just such a gangster and did an
incredible job so for the past like six
years i've done ulthera once a year
which is like a laser that traumatizes
uh your skin so intensely that it starts
producing collagen which is what
tightens everything so micro needling i
think does the same is the idea it does
the same thing i haven't done it enough
to be able to speak to it but i did do
micro needling a couple times and they
put like stem cells or some kind of like
you know
your own prp from your blood is what
they try to say to do but so for me
that's something that look i don't get
facials i don't go to facialists like i
just it's too time consuming for me and
the stress it would cause to go get the
facials every week yeah to drive there
that ages you know stress is what ages
do so i for what works for me is i do
this um derma rolling and then put the
product in every night i just think
something you're doing every day is a
regular thing is going to have a bigger
impact and going like i'm going to just
sort of like treat my skin like shit and
then once a week get a facial yeah you
know so i try to not rely on something
to fix what could have just been
maintained on a daily basis so i think
this is a better way to do it to just
derma roll every night and never do it
in the morning because uh you're gonna
go out in the sun in some capacity but
you also have to build up a tolerance to
it so when you first have you ever use
that no like
like
yeah so it's like it's it's gonna feel
wonky and especially over your lips but
make sure when you derma roll you never
skip your eyebrows right under your eyes
over your lips
right and then under your neck and your
neck and this jawbone because a lot of
times we try to just put product on our
foreheads
on our cheeks and chin you're like well
you're missing your lips you're missing
your the skin under your eyebrows you're
right i never do that and sort of stuff
like that so it's like it's just this
has changed my life
[Music]
[Applause]